gosh I'd say there's probably two
misconceptions that Americans have about
slavery that are pretty dangerous one is
we don't have slavery here which we do
we absolutely do and the other is the
other is that it's all about enslavement
if they know about slavery they think
it's all about enslavement into
prostitution of women from overseas
now that the facts are that very
conservatively measured very
conservative measure would say we have
probably 50,000 people in slavery in the
United States and some people would put
that number much higher but what we also
know is that the number of people who
are enslaved in sexual exploitation into
prostitution is less than half of that
total to the best of our understanding
now again it's a hidden crime it's a
criminal you know episode so it's hard
to get the tight numbers but to the best
of our understanding and so what that
means is that slavery exists all around
us in the United States and people tend
to be very unaware of it and and and
literally it could be in in your
neighbor's backyard it could literally
be in the restaurant where you had a
meal you know a few nights ago and so
forth and what we're missing then is the
idea that slavery is in our country that
it's actually always been in our country
there's actually never been a day in the
history of the United States with pal
slavery but of course the other I guess
if it's a misconception or really a big
idea that nobody has quite cracked come
to grips with is that we could actually
be a slave free country and we could be
a slave free country in a way that would
be a first in human history
the government has promised that we will
not have slavery in this country in the
same way that the police say you know
we're going to do our best to make sure
there's no murderer in this country well
when you compare the amount of money
which is in the in the low 100 million
zone to stop the crime of slavery in
this country and you compare it to the
billions about four and a half billion
which are spent on homicide you begin to
realize these two extremely serious
crimes are not getting the same
treatment and a perfect example of this
is that the State Department suggests
that something like 17 thousand people
are brought into the country every year
to be slaves trafficking victims 17,000
every year two in the United States to
be new new slaves in America the
homicide rate in the United States is
almost exactly 17 thousand a year as
well so we've got 17,000 new slaves and
we got 17,000 murder victims and yet we
spend over four billion on the homicide
and under a hundred million on the
slavery we have a homicide detective and
unit in every Police Department in the
country and how many slavery and human
trafficking units we have last count I
made was about seven twenty thousand
police departments maybe seven of them
have anybody want even an individual
part-time who's devoted to slavery it's
a very odd situation that we have a
crime almost as serious as murder
getting no attention and that's that's
one of the things we've got to do to
make this a slavery country